hello everybody hello hello before we begin i want to say a huge shout out and thank you to marvel rivals for today's sponsor yay so today we are checking out the season for early access so there's gonna be there's a lot of new changes and they introduced a new character which is angela uh who is a new vanguard slash tank and apparently she can fly and holy fucking abs I didn't know who they were going to add this new season.
So, like, you know when the trailer dropped?
And then I was just like, oh, my God.
When the trailer dropped and, like, her abs were, like, bigger than her, like, her torso, where her abs were, were, like, bigger than her head.
And I was like, oh, my God.
So, so, they were going to be checking that out.
And all the new skins, all the new costumes, the new biopad.
um all the new pat like uh the buffs and nerves for oh i think the funniest patch note for this season was that they made uh scarlet witch basically like a nuclear bomb so they're like we've adjusted scarlet witch damage she now does 999 damage i was like what the oh 9 000 9999 damage from like what was it what was before like 500 it was like she had 800 it was like we've adjusted scarlet witch ultimate from 800 to 9999 and i was like oh my god like now yeah it's like it's like a walking nuclear bomb that they no more mutants She is.
She is the hydrogen bomb now.
So, it's going to be very interesting to check out the new season.
So, like I said, huge shout out.
And thank you for my arrivals for giving me this opportunity.
So, thank you.
And you guys want to try out my arrivals for free, by the way, right now.
You can click on the link on my panel or pin in my chat.
So, yeah.
All right, let me save the sound settings.
I need to remember to save.
the sound settings for my last stream because i always forget by the way um i need i need to like make that like second nature for me because i always forget to do that and it's bad that's not good when i forget to do that all right let's check out the new season yay i know free we love free stuff okay we're gonna watch the intro because it's so bad the trailer was so cool but daredevil you see that apparently it's matt murdock matt murdock is the is daredevil oh my god it's so cool the trailer was so fucking cool um all right so new skins oh yeah this one this is apparently a new event so you can get ultron okay not gonna lie this ultron skin is pretty sick i i love wasteland concepts um but all right where is that battle pass all right Oh,
new Luna skins?
Yeah.
I forgot about the battle pass before, but...
Oh, my God, it's like fire and...
Oh, light and dark.
Light and dark are what's been dividing the line, but these two force...
Okay, let's buy this.
We'll buy it.
We gotta try out the new Luna skin anyway.
Oh, she's like...
Is it like Phoenix Luna?
Alright.
Wait.
Oh, I thought it was a cone.
Oh my god, it coils around her It coils around her boob I thought it looked like a cone And I was like, oh my god She's like, uh, Madonna
I was her emotes Oh, let's actually skip to the skins first Oh, winter's veil Okay, this Oh Oh no money wait how do i how do i fast pass oh upgrade all right nice upgrade please it's fine it's fine they gave me a lot of money look see i'm like i'm rich forever on for only this for one day i can be rich forever for one day okay i think this starlight skin is really sick holy fuck it's me this is basically me if i'm evil which i'm not this is actually okay not gonna lie this is this is the best if only i play star lord if only it's perfect in every way for me except that i don't play star lord oh man the only the only negative is that oh i just don't play starlord it's perfect in every way the only con is just that i don't play starlord just just one tiny con you know just that is such a cool skin wait what does he do oh my god he does the cosmic shuffle look at him go what a nerd
Look at him go.
Look at him shuffle.
Oh, it's the classic Captain.
It's the comic book Captain.
Okay, that's sick.
I like that.
Okay, but oh, I like.
Oh my god.
Finally, the people get what they wanted.
That.
That's America's ass right there.
Oh, say, can you see?
the gold truly is the golden age chat usa usa usa does he have anything new oh he sits in oh he gives detention okay that's silly um yeah we need a talk all right old man hot guy what do you want me to do beg you think because i'm old and blind i'm going to give you that satisfaction do your worst oh he's like a a gilf right that's no not dill it's the other one he's older than that guys he's older all right i mean that's pretty cool this skin is really cool too hot guy not even unc he's literally going he's literally i used to be an avenger i he's literally an old man oh he's just blue um blue but i do but apple but oh no okay honestly the skin might not be the best skin but the dog makes up for it that is so cute he's bringing his dog to I still get...
He's bringing his dog to war, isn't that great?
X-Men.
Oh, goodbye X-Men.
See, I like her.
She hates mutants too.
I mean, he is, or yeah, but what if the...
What if they're fighting a ghost?
Alright.
Nice.
There's a new Dark Phoenix skin.
There is Immortal Firebird.
I don't know how to...
Alright, exchange.
you know i might as well grab loki and try out his new oh i heard they like i heard they like uh got a bat and like was like you can't walk anymore uh i heard they nerfed him that's why he has new legs guys he had to get leg replacement surgery uh it's loki bird is he like oh he's based off of a phoenix yeah i heard they nerfed loki too i was this the trial of needle let me put a giant M on my on my abs I mean it accentuates his abs that's for sure
what's this what's this emo oh he's locked up up for his crimes for treating mutants well oh shit mechanite
oh shit that is cool Oh my, okay, Mecha Knight is pretty cool.
If only I play Moon Knight.
It's random bullshit time!
Oh my god, he's going ape mode.
He's charging up.
Go, go, Mighty!
Wait, he's that big?
Okay, I might be a little too OP, guys.
Like, in the patch notes, it'll be like, Um, we've made Moon Knight 80 feet tall and that's it.
Like go go 90 of it.
Wait, that's so cool.
I know he was an actual mecha.
Holy shit.
If he's 80, Moon Knight is now 100 feet tall.
We've made his hitbox, but it's still the same hitbox.
You just gotta figure out which one's the head.
He changed size, but like the hitbox is still like his old hitbox.
He just gotta figure out which one is ahead.
Oh yeah, this spray is pretty hard.
Goes really hard.
I like, I love, I love this.
This one's my favorite.
And then, oh, if only they had like, I don't know, rocket underneath his foot.
That would have been like the best part.
stand on you can squish someone at the end if only then it would have been perfect all right finally all right it's time it's time to check out angela so i saw a little bit of the videos of angela's gameplay and like basically she flies it's like a flying tank so you don't know i mean to be fair like she's huge so you'll know exactly where she is but it's also a little scary because That requires us to look up.
And we know gamers don't look up.
She's also four out of five.
I didn't know who Angela was before the reveal.
Because, like, you know, I'm a Marvel normie.
I'm a Marvel normie.
So, like, mostly the things I know about Marvel is, like, the cinematic universe.
So I didn't know that she was actually...
She's actually one of, like, Thor and Loki's sisters.
um just like hella so i didn't know that because um so that was really interesting so she's like she's like part of the family part of the asgardian family um so here are her skins oh what's this skull 20 oh wait that skin is okay that skin is sick that's like it's like cyberpunk ish Oh,
first appears.
Oh, they made this.
This first appears in Marvel Rivals.
So, like, Marvel Rivals specifically designed the skin.
Because I was like, oh, what comic is this from?
But they designed it.
Oh, but it's...
I'm sorry.
But it's perfect in every way, except it hides her abs.
Yeah, no abs, 0 out of 10.
It's almost perfect.
I need my ab window.
It needed an ab window.
So true.
It should have been transparent.
There should be an option where you can toggle an ab window.
And it's like toggle on and off.
So you can show.
Just as you're about to kill someone.
You toggle the window on.
So at least it gets a little something before they die.
The real.
Oh yeah.
What's the MVP like?
Imagine the customization.
Oh, they added a new...
They added a ton of new customization.
Like, you can design, like, your track colors now, too.
Yeah, this MVP skin...
MVP one is pretty sick.
All right, what about the emotes?
Ooh.
For heaven!
All right.
I know some of you guys wanted to look at the...
Oh!
Okay, the Lord!
The Lord is really sick.
I like that.
I actually, I really like the Lord icon for this.
For those who want to see it better.
That's actually pretty sick.
Compared to the default, this is actually a really good Lord icon.
Yeah.
I like that.
All right.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, that's just Asgardian language.
I was like, what's that on the bottom?
That's your name.
All right.
It's time.
Lunge forward with your spear dealing damage.
Oh my God.
Look, she's flat.
Wait, do I have like...
Oh, she flies all the time.
oh there guys there's no wait yeah she it's like she literally can fly the entire time she's always hovering okay that's interesting yeah she fly fly poor mechino mechino still doesn't know how to fly all right this is axes oh and then this one is oh that pulls people in Upon impact,
Assassin's Charge.
Yeah, she can fight the Flyers.
She's literally the tank for Vanguard's.
Like the tank against Flyers.
Oh, that's interesting.
Oh my god, okay, now I know why she's four stars.
Look at all these abilities.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's a lot.
Okay, I'm glad I'm not a Vanguard main.
I'm glad that is a lot.
in the shield gaining attack charge when absorbing damage okay transforms anchors into a shield okay so that's her shield so she can pull out a shield make the sky switching back to okay and then she then do like a slam dunk wait what's the difference between this one dive downwards switch to oh wait is it two different attacks wait i don't understand oh within the zone gain enhanced speed and attacks grants bonus help to self-end your oh she can heal her allies oh with this weapon okay i get it and then this is her fly look at her go wee wee all right what's her passive
apparently people are saying that thor is gonna be really broken this season or the new season oh yeah what about the new team ups i didn't really read much about the new team magic right or yeah magic what does magic do oh it's chained together okay uh chains two enemies and slows them the further they are apart the greater okay so basically basically that you guys have to stick close together yeah which sucks because everyone when you're against magic the key is you're supposed to not be together when you're against magic because then her her her sword can just like slash you through that's gonna be really rough oh this one i heard i saw this one it's basically when you're low hp you get your own like little bubble to be safe all right let's go practice range tab
practice range all right the new tank looks very difficult to play, only because like, I feel like just lying around is always hard to move when you're in the air, in general.
And then like, she has a lot of moves.
Okay, that right click is her shield.
I'm like a crow that's like here to terrorize like, get out of here!
This is my territory!
Just stabbing down.
Just burp things, you know?
Alright.
I mean, I hope she gets a crow costume.
I mean, it would fit.
Okay, that's a shield.
And then...
Oh, I heard you can do, like, a...
Environmental kill with this.
I saw, like, in the trailer.
If I can hit it.
Okay, this one's a...
This is a little hard to control.
This is a little hard.
Okay, that's a cooldown.
Depending on how far you want to take him, it's a cooldown.
But it feels...
It feels a little difficult.
I got trapped in first, you're right.
And then go with it.
Oh, wait, I can't fly.
Oh, I can't fly when I trap them?
Wait, is that...
Wait, how do I...
Oh, oh, wings.
Oh, okay, I get it.
I get it.
There is a cooldown.
there is a cooldown when I try it yeah I become melee when I do that oh I see it and then oh there you go and I can fly after I land down and I go fuck you can tell I'm not a Vanguard player it's very it's it's a lot it's actually it's so much information it's a lot of info this one this is a tank where you gotta have a big ass brain up there okay and then it drags okay so can they like get out of that i wonder wait can they get out of that team up where's the alt queue angela can leap the spirit damaging surrounding enemies and creating divine judgment upon impact buys oh it binds them so they can't okay i see gotta fly why would you never want to fly to me it's so it's already so hard to hit a flying target to be fair all right oh they can't leave look at them that's right you're in my world now Oh,
wait.
Oh, that's scary.
I can't leave yet.
Oh, you guys want a nicer view?
Give me a sec.
Alright, where is she?
Where's Angela?
Oh, wait.
And then...
Give me a sec.
Knowing is literally half the battle.
Is that...
There you go.
Now I can go.
Don't say I don't give nothing to you guys.
This is the perks of me having early access, guys.
You're like, okay, now I can leave the stream.
I got one.
I don't want it.
Death by Snooshnu.
Now we are talking.
See?
Don't say I don't give you nothing.
She is so... She is so much.
Like, my brain is like... Like... Not running at, like, any...
My brain is on dial-up right now.
Trying to understand her playstyle.
It's just so much in general.
I think the shift is gonna be really fun, though.
For sure.
pull down.
That's how I want to go.
Put me in, Coach Astaria.
Thank you for the thousand goodies.
Thank you.
I feel like you have to like, what's the word, be able to juggle between lying and being on the ground.
Like knowing when your team needs you on the ground and knowing when you have to be in the air and stuff.
I feel like she'll have like a lot.
She certainly has a lot of movement abilities in general because of how she can just switch utils.
Especially if she wants to be anti-air or, I guess, grounded.
Does her axe track?
Okay, I mean, I can try.
Alright, let's see.
I don't think so.
But her range is pretty good.
Wait, what?
Wait, okay.
Okay, it's here.
I can hit people from here.
Basically.
Yeah, this is her- this is the range of her act- Rep.
She's abusing the hitbox!
That's how far the range is.
Um, um, for, uh, for a melee.
I mean, I could try the air attack too.
Let's see.
Extendo arm.
Okay, how far?
I mean, it's a very long axe, guys.
I must heal soon.
Oh, wait.
That's...
Whoops.
I forgot.
My descend key is...
Wait.
Do I have...
Can she descend?
Give me a sec.
I gotta know.
Can she descend?
No, I just had it.
I'm buying it.
There you go.
There we go.
Okay.
I was gonna be like...
I was like...
That would be fucking weird if she can't fly down.
That's the range.
How far is that?
I'm pretty...
I'm pretty high up above him.
I'm literally about to, like, stomp him on it.
I'm not even close to stomping him on his head.
But my axe is pretty long.
Okay, it's up here.
This is how high I can.
That's pretty high up.
I could just...
It would be like, she's right above me, isn't she?
And I'm like, poke!
It's a long-ass spear.
Poke!
Oh my god, I'm so high.
Look at me.
I'm just pecking at their head.
I'll be like, it's feeding time, children.
It's aura farming, hey.
Alright.
Let's see.
I mean, I think there's not really a lot of new team-ups.
It's just really this.
Alright.
Oh, I just got hit them.
Okay.
How far?
Okay, wait.
Practice settings.
Okay, yeah.
It doesn't have to be directly at them.
Like, here.
That's the closest I can get.
Yeah, they can still separate when they're dead.
I guess you can say that, you know?
I guess you can say that when they're dead.
You can separate.
Yeah?
It's so death do us part.
I mean, the hitbox is like here.
It's like here.
Oh, you can kill.
It does a lot of damage, too, for it.
I heard they buffed her as well, but I don't play magic.
I cannot understand melee characters.
And that's why I'm not a Vanguard player.
I can't understand at all, like, how to play melee.
I don't know.
It's just something about it.
Why?
I just, like, I don't like punching.
I just rather just shoot my gun.
like and then it's basically this one is just what is this just passive you don't you can't set it off yourself I'm not shoot me shoot me oh show one that's all all right yeah I can do that I mean is loot all right let me yeah all right what would be a good here is it oh there you are I'm pulling them It's like they're just dead.
You can't survive a hydrogen bomb That's basically it I mean I feel like They get pulled I wonder like if you can like actually walk away a little I assume you can't I assume it's like an emma alt where where uh Where like uh You can't even like not look at them.
It's literally in the vicinity in any.
Because at least an ML just don't look, you know?
Just close your eyes for the ML.
Then you won't get mind controlled by her.
Just close your eyes.
But here you can't even close your eyes.
If you're like within the range, you get dragged in.
Yeah, she doesn't she doesn't, she can't mind control you if you just close your eyes.
What's my damage?
9,000.
But it's because I insta kill everybody.
There you go.
I mean, I can instantly kill her.
Yeah, see, I'm slowly coloring it.
So it's basically like no one can live.
No, it's not 999.
It's 9,999.
And for those who weren't here earlier, it's basically the old damage was 800.
And then they're like, that's not good enough.
We want her to erase people from existence.
So now it's 9,000.
Scarlet Witch.
Because they're like, it's not accurate enough.
She has to actually destroy everything.
Yeah, because like apparently Groot used to live through her old.
Oh, so they're like, we don't like that.
Fuck trees.
The good old Tyajun bomb.
Strat.
And then, that's why they created Mecha Knight!
HP is actually, um, Mecha Knight's HP is actually 10,000, so he would be the only one that can live through her all.
Alright, I think that's, is that all, like, the biggest changes that they did?
I know they did, like, what was it?
Oh, they buff Moon Knight, so she has he can do, oh, wait, as the overnight travelers.
So the thing they buff Moon Knight is that this, she has two of this now.
So for those who don't know, her is right.
So he can do two of this, and apparently is really strong.
Yeah, no survivors.
I didn't even kill Squishies now with this.
I'm pretty sure.
Alright, let's...
Oh yeah, Squish...
1 HP Squishies, yeah.
Oh yeah!
Jeff Alt got chain.
Yeah, so you can...
So if you have two...
Oh, I didn't buy the skin yet.
I'll do it later.
Yeah, so you can...
But it's like an 8 second cooldown.
So you have to wait.
wait that's a lot yeah i mean one blade was already alive um what else was it it changed oh jeff oh yeah the main arm is up is more of a heal now so let me grab that so basically this pool of all this pool heals now yeah so when i all i create a healing pool They didn't even change him.
They just made it so that every time I ult, I create a healing pool.
And so he can actually heal people while...
So it could be a defensive ult now.
Which is nice.
Also, they finally nerfed New Luna.
They finally made her, like, a little weaker.
Like, 1%.
Oh, my.
Wait, she has, like, a tail?
Oh, God.
That's so distracting.
I'm sorry.
That's...
I don't know if I can play with this it's a little distracting the tale it's a little distracting for me um but they made it so that her alt her alt is oh is this new oh it's a new song oh I'm not used to that it is a new song so it's a lot oh my god it's a lot shorter feel like I can like go have a bathroom break while in the middle of a Luna all now I remember when you can like get a bathroom break go out to buy some groceries come back and all is still going so then you just you decide to walk your dog then your Loki copies you and then you're like you know what maybe I should pay do my taxes while I wait for the second Luna all get some coffee and feels a lot shorter um oh she can finally rest her voice now and then you and then after the low-key cop is you and done and then you have your luna alt again and those two seconds actually feels a lot shorter because i feel like the old alt i can like i can like go have a bathroom break make coffee and walk my dog and come back and the
fight is still going on but now now i can only all right and now I just only have a bathroom break try Loki I don't think they change anything um with Loki Loki is consistently being nerfed no you don't understand Loki you guys should be lucky Loki didn't come in as beta Loki um um because during open during closed beta Loki was so
killed Loki during closed beta was so broken it was so bad um they basically nerfed his his damage you can get his ult so fast and basically like kill the entire lobby it was crazy like I was I was basically playing Loki the entire time is how strong he gets yeah so he doesn't do as much damage this is three loci's by the way look how little damage I do with three loci clones all right Okay,
actually no, it's not the fact that I do that much healing with three low-key clones All right All right, low-key clones you go over here You go here now.
I want to see how much healing I do with one.
Oh, that is that is scary
He does he does not a lot of heals guys.
He is by himself
yeah he does not do a lot now he does not do a lot by himself like usually the best part is just his clones but it's not a lot of heals because i'd usually never try to heal by myself so you can like abuse the low-key heals but even then it's not that much heals now which is nice because i i okay which is not nice because i just got low-key lord i actually spent so much time to get loki lord i finally i finally got loki lord and they took up they took loki to the alleyway and i never saw him again i'm so sad i love oh yeah they buff ultron too it's all it's all there's like uh it's up there's a lot of damage now apparently from what i've heard they buff ultron's I can't tell because I don't get to play Ultron that much.
So I don't know how much exactly his alt does compared to his old one.
I'm so looking forward to the Mantis swimsuit skin.
Because they're releasing a second batch of...
They're releasing a second batch of Rival's summer outfits.
And the Mantis swimsuit skin is so cute.
Invisible Woman's skin, uh, no skin suit.
Invisible Woman's Summer's skin is so cute.
I love it.
I didn't earn my favorites so far in terms of, like, the next, uh, next skins coming up.
Oh yeah, and then the thing gets a second summer.
Like, no, I was just reading the trailer.
I'm not reading, plah, watching the trailer.
And I was just looking at the new skins that's coming up.
Because I signed, like, cause, like, you know.
Um, I've been always being like, oh, I don't really like some of this, like, there's been like a lack of good support skins.
I feel like the ones coming in for the next batch look really, really good.
Yeah, that's right.
I never read.
I just watch.
Oh, yeah, any buff invisible woman.
Her alt is better now.
Uh, she apparently...
Apparently her alt does...
It slows people down more.
I mean, we could try it out on these guys.
Holy shit.
Okay, wait.
Wait.
How slow are they?
I need to know.
Okay.
I can't...
They feel a lot slower.
Alright, let's try.
Let's try for these guys.
Oh!
They feel a bit... Yeah, they feel a lot slower in general.
So apparently, they slowed down people inside the ult.
And they increased the healing, I believe, right?
I don't remember exactly the patch notes, but I think that was what they did.
And then you'll notice it when you're in a fight more.
I like this chain, the Jeff one.
But you have to remember where you are.
You can't flank alt now.
Oh, I can...
I didn't know that was the feature.
I usually never look at that.
Whoa.
Wait, I can do a top-down view?
Okay, I'd never pay attention to Jeff.
Yummy, yummy.
I clearly don't pay attention.
Yeah, the Jeff all heals.
Wait, oh my god, it heals so much.
Wait, you're right.
Wait, this heals so much.
I just noticed that.
Yummy, yummy.
Alright.
What else?
I think...
Is there any other changes that they did?
I know they nerfed Scylok.
Thank fucking God.
I'm so tired of Scylok.
Finally.
Finally, as a support player, I can finally fight back.
I say coping.
I say copingly.
I don't know what exactly they buffed.
But...
What exactly they nerfed.
They nerfed something.
A true warrior is not defined by strength.
I can finally live an extra second, I say, as a coping support main.
A coping lunar support main.
That's even worse.
All the other support mains are like, you already have everything.
It's like, I want more.
Okay, so what is it?
This?
Oh, how far is it?
Wait, can I be like here and do it?
Oh, wait, that's so cool.
Okay, I have to hit someone.
Yeah, it's like, it's a dive.
So I have to hit someone to be able to do it.
Oh my god, imagine like a diving Thor is actually pretty scary.
Okay, if I can hit that.
all right wait let's see if i can hit him oh it's a projectile though so that's like the worst part i'll get it eventually well it was only okay i think like an actual sword may will be able to hit that it's not me there you go oh wait there's a range oh there's a range oh thank god okay Okay,
thank God.
I was gonna say if I was Imagine if a Thor threw his spear From like spawn Like in the Thank God Imagine a Thor through his spear From spawn and just Threw straight down And it hits somebody And then you're like where the fuck did this guy come from Okay,
at least there's a range At least Yeah, a lion floor is already Pretty scary Okay All right, let's see.
Even that.
Oh, you can actually whiff the slam.
I wonder if, like, if they move.
Eee!
All right, wait, actually, how...
If they're moving, do I land on where they're going?
Or...
I don't know.
I can't tell yet.
I can't...
Oh, can someone walk in too?
it oh we can try the cooldown is crazy though it's like 22 seconds oh oh okay i can i can leap anywhere i don't have to hit it okay i actually oh i can use this to fast travel oh okay it was literally just range i can try fast travel with this i just gotta get closer there we go yeah it's an area it's not a character i think if it hits a character it travels with them.
I'm pretty sure.
I think that's what it means.
If you hit a character, it just travels with them.
If I hit it.
Guys, the only issue is that I have to hit it.
That's the only issue.
Look, I never said I was a projectile player.
There we go.
Yeah, it travels with him.
Yeah, see?
So if you hit it, it just... Yeah, you hit it.
If you hit it, you can travel with the spear.
range and it's pretty interesting these little changes every every half season you get a little something like a little surprise all right i think that's everything right or any other changes you don't have to run away from your past yeah it's good for if you're chasing someone if you hit it so so like if you hit them you can chase the squishies is there anything oh what the fuck where did you get that scar i can you tell me that story
hey girl you tell me the story how you got that scar at the local bar if you want
whoa nope i spy some bad guys Scarlet, uh, uh, yeah, oh my god, you can exchange stories about how you got the scar!
Oh my god, we're perfect for each other.
Penny, spider drones, is that a new buff?
Oh my god, can Penny players finally play?
Oh wait, it's time, okay, I gotta, we gotta go, it's team time.
All right, give me a sec.
don't know sound guy if you're here it's time for custom who's my team it is okay let me disable streamer mode first so i can see oh i did it is j3 craiggy uh uh ninja tim and las and wait there's one more who's and oh wait j3 ninja tim las craiggy and me yeah yeah i gotta play with tim the tatman and ninja and j3 and craiggy is that six am i missing one i can't tell i'm not counting all right let's see uh custom game is it or is it called angela joins okay is this one all right i join in i'm gonna be scared and shy The only person I recognize is the only person I've ever actually talked to in this group is none of them.
So it's going to be, I'm going to try my best.
That's, that's a little awkward.
It's, it's actually none of them.
I've never talked to any of them before.
So, whoa.
Oh no.
New people.
Oh.
i'm always so bad with with these things uh let me see hey i'm bald no he's bald by he's bald by choice tim whips is there a new map wait hold on your airline bro that thing is running away from you at full speed damn like full sprint you're gonna take that i don't even think tim could grow Tyler,
do you think he can grow Taylor?
I'm muted, by the way.
I don't think this got like about a week to go, man.
You know, actually, I think it was like six, seven days ago.
It's what map, what map do we go, bro?
Oh, whoa.
Wait, is the new map not in the game?
I don't think it is.
I don't see it.
Oh, yeah, the new map is like next, next month, apparently.
Okay, bye.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sorry, next week.
Next month.
Hello, Doki.
Hello.
Hello, hello.
I think we just play any.
listen all I know is that they they don't have a Venom Andrew on their team I'm going to have so much fun oh yeah no we will have a we should play Midtown who is the other guy yeah do you want to do Midtown or something yeah yeah yeah Midtown is so good Midtown bro you there Doki do you play Jeff uh I can try normally I don't play I don't play him either but I want to I want to test out his healing oh yeah get off the thing yes Jeff ulti now is nutter butters.
It looks cool.
So I actually, it's so funny.
I just saw this tech about like the 100 meter just starting to get by the way.
What people were doing, like, they were like old in their spawn with Jeff and then fly into the end of like the audio won't cue.
But now there's no reason to do that if the healing isn't going to drop.
So you want to Thor and all Angela first one and then you can swap it?
Yes, sir.
I'm going to try to kidnap X and just pull the pack.
out of him.
Hey, Yaman.
What the heck out of that guy?
The heck out of him, dude.
I'm so glad you were practicing your Thor thing, because now, like, this is a massive combo right here.
Yeah, you're Wombo-Tomba together.
You guys got to plan it.
I'm so happy we're playing Midtown, because the last preview, we made everybody play Midtown six times in a row, and XPC was in there.
I actually like this map.
Oh, yeah, I like this map here, actually.
keep me alive guys okay they're gonna bully me i'm so happy i got midtown yeah you got that new moon night costume on bro it never midtown never ends immediately when we join in here bro heck yeah did you guys even see me and moxie if they cannot get away from midtown
Yeah, but like, do you have wings?
I don't think so.
Ninja screen.
I already got it.
Got it.
Already.
Come on, I'm a professional, bro.
I feel like I'm going to push the card.
They're coming up top, probably.
This character, bro.
Oh, yeah.
I got the floor here.
Oh, my God.
I'm just flying away.
We're going to back up for now.
My last is we got point.
I pulled the floor.
Oh, there's a scooter man.
Oh, I got you.
I'm in there.
I'm gone.
Big heals coming in, Craig.
Big heals, brother.
Yeah, you'll never die.
I'm going to try to keep that back.
Moon Knight's onk is yellow.
Look at Thor.
I think it's the mecha.
Oh, yeah.
I'm bringing it back here.
Oh, I need help.
I'm getting killed.
I got you.
Big heals.
Protect our heal.
Nice.
Wait, yo.
These yellow hunts are sick.
Can you guys get in my E really quick?
Come here.
Is this buff you too?
Oh, is this gold?
Oh, that's yep.
No.
Do you run faster in it too?
It's just like aesthetic.
They're behind us.
Oh, I can't even pull that.
Oh, I need help.
I need help.
There's a Thor on us.
Oh, I'm low too.
Oh, I'm getting harassed.
I got you.
heals for life oh my god nice heals whoever that was
oh i'm going on moon night oh yeah yeah yeah i know you can you can oh you had the you try them i'll hold first yeah yeah i don't know who i'm gonna like i guess i'll just hold like obviously like class if you get your own let's try and combo it together bro like start the alt with what do i spit them out i'm only at 65 i don't know how to really get all honor ya uh you can spit them out behind us ah we got food behind him i push her away i pushed away she's low she's one huge that's a good ult i'm coming out i'm coming out i'm coming out Big heals coming in big heals.
How was the healing though?
Was it good?
Oh yeah, he doesn't get us 100 seconds.
I got Luna out.
Oh, we might be dead.
We might be dead.
Oh, we're alive.
Oh, no.
I killed her.
I killed like two zeros.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
We got the tactical news.
Nice heals.
Last I got you there.
I'm dead.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I got it.
All right.
We'll try and do it.
You ready?
Yeah.
I'm like, just stay alive, stay alive.
Yes, sir.
Are you ready?
No, she is.
Wolverine, look at her cap.
Oh, you are so, I don't know if you're living, yeah.
Oh, my God, that old is so sick.
You are not living that.
Oh, Scarlet low, Sky low.
Get them off.
Sky, what?
Sky?
I went too deep.
I tried to bully X.
Oh, my God, that was sick.
At least he didn't kill you.
That is so dope, bro.
That is freaking cool.
Oh, I don't see you.
I got you.
I feel like I can get back there in the past, too.
Wait, I'm going in with all of you.
Can I get some bubbles?
Yeah, bubbles going in.
Oh, God, I got kidnapped.
I pulled in.
Oh, wait, I got kidnapped again.
Oh, my God.
I got you.
Oh, oh.
I'm putting a shield up.
Ty, come here.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, nice heals.
I'm getting healed.
I got four!
I don't know where to take them!
Oh!
Go back, go back, go back!
Just take them to the room!
Look at the house!
We'll beat them up in the house!
There you go!
Nice!
Wait, Jeff main in the making.
Yeah, I think Jeff is better.
Oh, there's a wolf behind you guys.
Wolf behind you guys.
He's in this house.
Get him, Timmy.
Yeah, I am.
Down to three.
What if I could stop TP?
Dude, that was actually so sick, Craig.
Yeah, absolutely.
That was crazy.
Hang on for just feeling fantastic.
Oh, wow.
I don't think I'm going to grab him.
Sue brings me down.
I'm going to try to kidnap Xs all.
That's good to hear.
Oh, I got changed.
I got changed.
Oh, I'll be...
He's one.
Oh, I hear him again, bro.
Magic.
Magic behind us low.
X1.
Change what?
Where's the magic?
Magic for sure.
Oh, he is not dead.
No, no, it's a Jeff.
Oh, oh, okay.
I'm gonna go try to cancel a little TP.
Um...
I think I got it.
Hang on.
Oh, did C9?
I was gonna cancel.
I think I had XQC canceled there too.
Well, I can't believe it.
C9 in 2025?
who's a cute little jeff come on bro that's my that's my duo partner lately dude hey come on now baby put ninja down a little apparently we sang at is there like a whips is there a competitive game mode so we would have switched sides there uh yeah probably just i think they wanted us in quick play didn't they the game mode is quick match did they want us in quick play yeah yeah oh my bad all right we'll just do a different map then uh we can just swap size that's what i'm saying it's like it didn't give them a chance whatever just do do whatever waves pick one lest you can you can uh angela this time yeah how was she she's fun i i'm dude she almost i don't know how to play front line with her at all to be honest i don't think you're supposed to that's it she felt very i think she's like a diver isn't she yeah she's almost like a dive vanguard like you just dive supports like captain america yeah no the mid max the bin max is going to be pretty in pretty insane she's off angle she's
flanking she's i mean i wish we got defense i think a lot of people are gonna play her like there's like hovering the air and then fly behind them and get them kidnapping your supports like on accident i wasn't even really wait by the way is this luna's old nerfed here it is yeah it's there are two seconds yeah so they just took two seconds away what it's so it's eight instead of ten or six instead of eight it's ten instead of 12.
sorry about that it was 12 seconds yeah you can have a bathroom break in the middle of her all i could probably my bathroom's right next to me i probably could do it i guess i'll be right back as long as they don't have the hawkeye bro look leo look at this look at this brother can you hear her right click on this this is so fire look at the right click yeah her left click sounds so good you can hear Oh,
it sounds like it just sounds it's out.
Yeah, it sounds close.
It's so sick All right, meow if you want my snowflake and Yo,
Jay you want the snowflake, no?
Guys, come on.
All right, let's go in for last last gets it.
Oh, it's last Yeah, what's so damn funny?
Meow.
What?
Are y'all mad about?
This team, the team up with, dude, Thor mains are going to be eating good.
Yeah, does Thor feel really strong now?
I'm assuming.
Last is a lot better than I am on him.
Alright.
Don't worry, that's...
I give you Ultron so you can 1v1 him.
Moxie's one shot, Spider-Man.
Alright.
I'm on point.
Damn, you're so gone.
I went too deep.
That's fine.
We got more.
Why is Moxie on Spider-Man, bro?
He wants to pull you off for a clip, for a TikTok clip.
Oh!
You got one.
I got you a...
I got you an Ultron mix.
Crack gets really hard to heal.
You're constantly in, uh...
Yeah.
I got Luna.
Oh, that's another one.
Oh, man.
That kidnap is nice.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, he blocks it.
He's half.
Yeah.
Super's half.
Super's one.
Invictus only healer on their left side.
Spider-Man bag.
Spider-Man on me?
I might need help.
I got you.
He's on.
That's a vault.
We didn't push that, can we?
Spider-Man weak still.
I need heal.
I need us.
Thank you.
I got you.
Got you.
Okay.
Spider-Man, I'm going Spider-Man against him.
One blade.
Wait, Susan Viz.
Where'd she just go?
Listen for her footsteps.
Yep, quiet.
Oh, there's a Spider-Man here.
I smell her?
Mark Spider-Man right here?
I'm cooked, I'm cooked.
Bro, how are you supposed to hit a Spider-Man that knows what they're doing?
Like, actually.
Oh, I gotta get out.
He's trying to kill me.
Oh, I got you.
I'm using my luck.
Love y'all.
I got one.
All right.
You two, you two.
No, I'm gone too here.
I'm on the point.
But I might die.
You want to combo it?
Hell yeah, bro.
You guys have no healers.
You just wait.
All right.
Oh, we are.
They use Invisal for that.
Yep.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think they have like every other alt impossible though.
I'm ready to dive.
You got, you got to get in there and get ready.
All right.
I'm ready last.
I'm gonna try to do it.
I'm on Spider-Man.
For the cinema.
Come with the healers.
Oh shit!
Oh they did to us.
Oh my god that's a lot of damage.
Oh my goodness.
That is a lot of damage.
I think we're dead.
I'm also.
Nah it's gotta be doable.
I don't think this is...
It's winnable.
It's just two.
I played one.
look at this team let's go oh nice poke okay craggy come on baby oh let's go oh my goodness actually heal through that combo last i think they actually used everything it last us we could uh you and me should come back all right brother you got midnight wait wait wait get someone in last and i'll pull them back even further you got it brother here we go don't fight king spider
Oh, I'm a poor guy.
Oh, I scared such a freak.
What are you doing?
I need help.
I'm on point.
Help me!
Swarm me.
Oh, I'm on Luna.
I'm on Luna.
Oh, yeah, Luna's out.
Do I throw like a girl?
Nice.
Nice here.
I lost MVP there after that death.
Honestly, it was deserved.
i suggested midtown so it's deserved uh what was the sue buff by the way what was what was the buff oh her her alt it makes people go slower now uh 165 to 180.
heals for second whoa that needed to happen too okay cool yeah i kind of felt the luna nerf there a smidge which is actually like i mean she's so busted so i like it like her kit is still so good i think she's still just to be like magneto right you just like need like a good mag like you'll know when you're playing a good luna regardless of two seconds of her old what is that bro the fact that the stream went straight to me and i was like please let me fly let me fly off the map here this game is so freaking sick dude i'm so shy yeah they cooked with a lot of the costumes bro it's insane last uh do you want me to save for you again uh you were jay Yeah.
Moxie's already here.
I'll save.
You can take people off the map in this last.
This would be sick.
Oh, my God.
Spider-Man pull.
That's Spider-Man's one.
Yeah, he got the health back.
I'm shifted right now?
Oh, super gone.
You can shift people off too.
Oh.
I got my alt less.
Oh, strange half.
Strange low.
I'm just beating him up.
Nice.
Let me get him here.
Oh, you got him, Greg.
Yeah, yeah.
Don't get pulled.
Last, let's try and do the combo with this choke, yeah?
Yes, sir.
Oh, I'm short of breath on that one.
Last, did you use your C into it or did you just alt into it?
I see it into it and then I drop my E and then I ulti.
All right.
I'm gonna throw mine in there with you guys.
Oh, Tim!
Oh, you left!
Nice play to me.
Oh, you just killed everyone.
Never mind.
Oh my god, you all live.
You tried to take me off the bat, dude.
Bro, that was so good.
Oh god.
I got you?
Oh, never mind.
I lied.
I'm booty.
I'm gone.
Goodbye.
I was in the wrong form, dude.
This map is going to be so troll.
I ulted as well.
I got three.
I'm saving.
Oh my God.
I got three.
Goodbye.
Big fish.
Oh, goodbye, Jay.
You can jump.
It's my turn to take people off the gift.
That was so good.
I didn't, I was like worried.
I don't know, I don't know how good is healing.
So I double ulted as well, even in the pool.
I think it's like, I think you definitely won't survive.
Like really, you can over, you can over commit very easily.
Sure can.
You just get so excited.
And fall.
Bubbles to escape.
Guys, he wants to win.
No, my dog!
My dog wants food!
Oh my god, I'm so slow!
I got a rod of the ult.
Oh, come on.
He wants food.
I can't talk!
I can't capture him!
I froze her!
I'm out!
I can't feed him!
We're fighting!
You can hear him!
He came!
Oh, we get closer!
Please!
I'm going in.
I'm going to capture him.
Please!
I'm fucking...
Oh my god.
Hold on.
I thought something happened.
I'm at work!
I got Wolf 2.
Oh my.
Oh my, I see all this.
Yeah.
One shot super nice.
Invisible one shot on point somewhere.
Oh my God, he came closer.
No!
No, the aim is coming on point one.
I got to get him fast.
Wow, was that really necessary?
Sure was.
Oh, yeah.
Nah, he's looking good, looking good.
I gotta showcase that Angela.
Oh my God.
Dude, that must have been so fun for her, bro.
Bro, he got me in three.
That map is going to turn in two hours early.
Because he knows that map works.
Spider-Man's pulling people off the map.
Fuckies, Wolverines.
He got his food two hours early.
This fucking dog is...
Oh my goodness.
He won.
aura the death bubble with her shift while she's flying you have your lightning speed oh really you go you're like a nascar i can only turn left but i was hauling i can go real left and real fast oh baby a tripper okay jeff is really fun to play he's really fun to play with the i don't know uh with his new world and everything i like it what do you call voice columns yeah it's true i mean we'll just run i'll do another i'll start another one i mean anyone else who else wants to play angela here guys yeah i would i would love to try it all right anyone else oh okay anyone but jason that's wild must be this tall for this ride brother go ahead jay weapons if i just be like the people in rank to just lock in and leave voice do it guys just leave vc just leave a discord server last last do you want to thor i will i can thor or phil i mean we'll get any changes just some more volume oh you know what i should play rwanda nope her all is crazy now bro yeah yeah that's what i was gonna play
next you should try it all right i'll last a little bit sam guy all right y'all i'm gonna play tim i'm gonna try to invisible woman i'm not used to that um i think muting okay come here
Let it recharge.
Try and heal me in this form, Ty.
I mean, I can't.
You're not taking damage.
Hit me with it.
All right, go ahead, Rip.
Oh my god.
The super.
Yo, Jay, Jay, you can take them off the map.
Bro, fly from behind right here.
Let's move up.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, we gotta move up.
Right here, stick them and throw them off the map.
Left click at the end.
Oh my god, this is gonna be insane.
Bro, this is clipping here if you can pull this off.
If I miss, I'm gonna feel bad.
I got you.
Hit me with it.
They don't know.
Oh, God.
You move that way.
Oh, shit.
We can't.
Oh, my God.
You can't go straight.
Oh, I got fooled by the water.
Oh, good grease wall.
The coast.
You're the only tank, by the way, Jay.
Goodbye, everybody.
I got group.
I'm the...
Where's Moxie?
Moxie above a sign of it.
Oh, he was shooting me.
Oh, I'm getting shot.
from behind.
Wait, he's one?
He's one, one, one.
Nice.
I'm clapping.
I can pull someone in a second.
I think I get healed in my shift form now, which is insane.
Dude, switch is insane.
Wanda's insane.
Oh, I got the new character.
Oh, you're well now?
You're trapped.
You're well.
You're all you want.
Oh, you're okay.
You're so healthy.
I'm not having fun I immediately shifted him.
Oh, Gru what?
Oh, never mind.
He's getting healed.
Why I'm pulling?
Oh, no, I missed my push.
Missed my push.
That's fine.
We can wait a bit here.
Throwing another shift.
Oh, nice.
Pulling in one second.
I'm a bit low.
I'm pulling Gru.
All right, Walt.
Easy.
What?
Oh, you almost got him.
He had more HP.
Oh, he's just, how did you bomb it?
How did you bomb it?
I didn't hit it.
Damn it.
I froze.
I got the Hulk out in.
Wait, I'll ult first.
Are you all first?
I'm okay.
Okay, never mind.
I got a second.
I'm pulling XECN.
Yeah, pulling him in even further.
Nice.
Oh my god, 4X, dude.
Yo.
I'm gonna ult.
I'm gonna ult towards the end of this.
That's a good ult.
That's a really good jump.
Okay, I'm in the...
I'm sitting in it.
I'm sitting in it too.
Oh!
Oh, you hit me.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I ult this.
No, I died.
Oh.
me in the middle i'm gonna go moon night i'm gonna try moon night they're charging my own right here oh my god frozen come on way back i'm dead i speed the oh i'm dead oh wait don't worry guys it's all points don't point i can see me i just realized we're solo heal no no no i'm playing with it one point i'm going to go heal I got you guys
Oh guys, I'm scared I'm putting X you see in the into our team damn you went to the portal
Close at the last second no, no, no, I'm telling you it closed at the last second bro with close I had everyone.
Where did our Wanda all go, guys?
Yeah, where did he go?
Oh, no!
I had it.
So you all didn't spy?
Guys, I got 10 minutes on Wanda.
Leave me alone.
That's crazy.
Wait, you have the team up.
You have the team up, Ryan.
Oh, goodbye.
You...
Left click and right click at the same time.
Oh, yeah, it's the... It's this, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yo, I'm dead serious.
I'm a Wanda man.
main from now on no one else talked to me maybe hit it all first before you say that alright alright alright let me click terrible moon at all terrible moon at all yo XQC is behind us oh yikes wait are you good oh wait well moon nights I love the uh the sound of moon by the way no one talked about his audio did you miss the whole shit thank you thank you I think I blocked the I blocked the old business.
Nice.
Here, I'm gonna, I'm all here?
Sorry, yeah.
I got there.
I froze fruit.
I kind of forced it anyways.
I'll let it too.
Okay.
That's a good all.
I'm stuck inside.
I'll zig them.
Got nobody?
Oh my god.
I can't hit anyone bro.
Oh my god, I'm getting hit by everything.
Oh no.
Oh.
Shit!
I go I go punny here I go punny here
damn have you killed anyone earlier okay dude just for life man right I am eating one I am contributing so what happened to your last what happened to that well X blocked it with the wall and I got really upset oh wait I can take people off the map here oh goodbye they get off the map here get him off the map oh miss i have to reload very soon ninja i'm trying so hard ember's weak yeah angelo angelo oh you got healed wow clearly good healing on her yeah no their their heels are being kind of like uncontested oh he wants to dive he's one she's one she's one and you care nice oh she wants to he's flanking Yo,
he's flanking.
He's going to the right over there.
He's going to...
I see.
I...
Oh, what did he do?
You got this.
I believe.
I got him.
Oh, I threw him over.
Wait, wait.
Oh, he's getting healed.
Thanks.
He's done.
Moxie trying to pull off my right click.
Come on now.
Oh, do you need help over there?
Yo, yo, yo.
Okay.
I have my own here for you almost.
You got the sim.
One kill.
Oh!
You did it!
Bang!
And then, wait, Ninja, how do you die?
I got pulled.
Oh, there are more on top?
Oh, no, like in front of us?
On all of us, dude.
That was actually sick.
Yeah, I'm about to ult.
Can I get heals?
Wait, Ninja, you want to combo?
I would love to.
What do we combo in, brother?
I'm stuck in that.
I saw it's all of them in the...
Oh, they support ult you.
That's not you.
Are you still ulting?
Wait, she's so slow.
Nice.
Come on now.
Yeah, you out damaged Luno.
Oh, we love it.
Mox is trying to kill me again, dude.
You already got me once, dude.
The PTSD.
Holy, dude.
If you stay in a turret form, you can never get pulled.
I'm never going to get off this.
I need all your shields.
I just got two tab by Super Bro.
Oh, my God.
Only 60 seconds left.
That's my Wanda.
I got one of the healers.
He embarrass me.
He does.
See, he can't pull you.
Oh, now he can.
Angela is it?
I got you.
Don't worry.
We actually love that.
I'm going for him.
Don't worry.
I knocked him down.
The right click's actually so good.
He's one shot.
Bro, he's so fast.
Yes.
He makes fast people look not fast.
Doesn't grab up?
There's a group up.
There's a group on the right.
There's groups on the right.
He might try to solo this.
Yeah.
He's not having a good time.
Wait, did you see him?
He's over here somewhere.
Oh, he's...
He's like, dude, I need some ammo, dude.
I need some ammo.
We're gonna mama combo.
I'm on the blink.
I'm stuck.
Stop.
What the fuck?
Hey, you're toxic, bro.
Hey, guys, here comes, here comes, here comes.
I want my combo.
Wait, what?
I do what?
I'm on the way.
Here we go.
Dude, I'm getting caught.
Oh, no.
The wall blocks it, man.
Oh.
Oh, nice.
How do we learn?
We're a resin dude.
Just get out of here, Jay.
Yeah, get out of here.
Oh, Shay got pulled.
What is Tyler's cross, sir?
Oh, my God.
It's actually amazing.
You can see my body.
I don't think so much damage is crazy.
I got you moving speed.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, my God, Dad.
You're so fast.
I've still got songs to see.
Good tea.
is zero to two i think i'm sweating time to switch things up bro yeah you're hating on the on the default punisher shotgun but i've never hit more shots in my life dude it was crazy i like the good vibes yeah good vibes because we're also winning goodbye it's the default crosshair it's the default shotgun punisher crosshair i didn't touch it it's like made that do you have even have your sense on i have my sense i have my sense memorized but i don't have the default i just did the default crosshair and i had no idea how dude the circle takes up half the screen like dude i'm not even joking just pull up the stream for or swing here swap the punisher if i know you guys probably have different crosshairs it's terrible i want to say pull it up but it's uh it's literally half the screen 30 seconds before you attack get ready winning equals good vibes I've seen a clip for gaming for gaming I mean I already forgot I hit I think we're doing pretty well I hit a zip line behind their team they
have like I just I don't know I thought like the team would be like pretty balanced because they have like do that right now do that right now do that right now the way they're both like right above all I won't be able to do Oh my god.
Wait.
He's aura farming.
He's aura farming right now.
Let him aura farm.
Hold on.
It's on.
It's on PC.
Someone to like the edge.
What is it?
How do you do it?
You have to bind it in your key key binds.
It says settings, key binds and then down to movement.
It's slow walk.
It's working to the strength.
Super distraction is working.
What the heck happened?
You guys gotta do better in the front line, dude.
You guys gotta do better.
Oh, there.
Aren't you?
Are you guys aura farming right now?
Yeah, we're all aura farming.
Wait, they're farming you.
You're also farming you.
Okay, dude.
All right.
Now we finally...
All bets are off.
Oh, my God.
I love how everyone kind of started trying at the exact same time.
Yeah, Moxie tried to kidnap me.
Oh, my God.
that's a proxies what oh no he got healed i see the nest i'm on the nest the nest is gone and now that's oh i'm sorry but let's see oh the wall you guys are walled i can't hear you guys oh my god so many walls i don't even know if this is enough healing but actually this might not be enough healing i'm swapping oh x is so weak i have my ult but no jimmy jimmy jimmy jimmy jimmy
high tails as well oh i'm dead i'm dead you were nice healed though that's crazy enjoy one nice i am ready to put on a show technically i'll damage this
but i don't know if you can live through this no my butt okay okay they used their only support alt las is gonna go in and eat everyone oh i'm gonna do it without them here and you ready dude i'm gonna do this here we go that's not fun i can try and time my alt with the adam warlock born again that could be kind of wild oh yeah yeah you ready oh the delayed old oh no man i got pulled off bro invisible woman bro she does that yeah she pushed me off man yeah i get that i get Oh,
I'm locked in that.
I got bubbles on the middle of the point.
Oh, I think I might die.
I'm all over the bubbles.
I'm dancing on the bubbles right now.
That's so much damage.
Nice, nice, nice.
Are you guys winning?
Yeah, we're winning, son.
Nice.
Yippee.
No way they portal, right?
Moxie's portaling for him.
Wait, wait, I got freeze ready.
Wait, I'll dash through the portal and try to push him off.
He's a slow poke.
Oh, he missed.
I still got to freeze.
I'm getting Muxia.
I'm getting Muxia out.
Nice.
Wait, wait, wait.
Go through the portal.
Wait, there's one.
Go in there.
I'm frozen right now.
I believe in yes.
I'll push the cart.
I think she got, she got me.
I'm targeting.
Oh, my God.
Wow, that is toxic, bro.
Oh, dude.
Sikuno's here.
I think they didn't realize they could go to, like, the other lobby.
Can they go to the other lobby?
Can they go to the swap swans?
Oh, no.
Oh, that's toxic, bro.
It's a penny angle.
I think he's all got a buff, right, or something.
She like had her kits slightly.
I thought Penny did.
Yeah, no, Penny did get them.
She spawned more mines now.
It is insane that you can heal Wanda in her shift now.
Wait, Groot's low.
Oh, he lives.
Yeah, I know.
I got him so weak.
Oh, wait.
Angela on us.
Bye.
Let me help.
I'm walking.
Oh, I know it's death.
Oh, wait.
Catch the dog.
I still got songs to sing.
You will never know.
And we're going to have the combo here.
So hit me.
Be safe.
Don't worry.
We're coming back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Live, live last.
No.
If you can peek me.
I can hit them close to an edge so you can like play the corner.
Yeah, I'm going to, yeah.
That's the hardest part.
I ignored there.
Let me know when you do it, Jett.
Okay, I'm looking.
I'm looking in main right now.
It's a big one.
This?
There's a jet behind us.
Oh, not Jeff.
Oh, dude.
Oh, my God.
She froze me.
I can't see back.
Don't hate it.
I'm coming.
Four, three, two, one.
Oh, I missed this.
I missed this.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
I live.
Get him off the map.
I hate so many people.
I didn't know how to.
I keep you up.
No, I quit.
Keep you up.
Oh no.
Oh, they're dying.
He's got the wrong people.
He's one.
That grid's one.
I'm stuck.
Oh my goodness.
I got grimsters.
She tethered me and I couldn't fly.
Damn it.
Are you okay?
She tethered me.
me and I couldn't fly.
Oh, I'm just chunking you off the map when you res.
I saw that.
I saw you like beating him up in the corner.
Why not point playing?
I'm point selling.
Is that Andrew on point?
Yes.
Oh, look.
No.
Oh, I got you guys.
I got you guys.
I got bubbles.
I got them.
I have to.
Oh, they still got it again.
They see nine, two, nine, two, nine, bro.
They see nine again.
Nice.
That's what I'm talking about.
Give up Vellanda, Tim.
Guys, I have thrived.
This is like my first full game on this character.
I'm learning, all right?
Hey, bro, hang up the.
Hang it up, dude.
Yeah, I mean, Ninja's top frag.
Come on, bro.
Okay, shouldn't you be top frag with your high fob?
All right.
Moon Knight is not my main character.
He's on Moon Knight.
Okay, okay.
I'm blanking, I'm blanking, I'm blanking.
They don't know.
Jay, oh my god.
Oh my god.
You just hold back.
You're hilarious.
Dude, super is nice.
That's crazy.
I'm ready to put on a show.
I have an Angela on me.
He's on the cart.
I'm just farming my old and that old Jay, by the way.
That was insane.
Oh, you're good.
Good stuff.
Okay, they might have a...
Oh, never mind.
Oh, he's dead.
You make one shot!
I frozen?
Wait.
Adam Orlac is like the greatest solo player of all time.
We have like six ultimates, by the way.
This is insane.
Wait.
We'll do you, you, you default first, you go ahead.
Bro, if you could, Jeffel, grab all of them and then just like, I'll throw my ult.
Yeah, they're all fighting in there anyway.
Oh, I fell down.
I fell down.
You fell!
Oh, you didn't stop that.
What?
That's...
Wow.
Wait, that's good.
That's good.
I am ready to put on a show.
I got it.
They're all back up though.
Strange as all.
Lusable.
Lusable game.
C9able.
I'm on it.
I'm not leaving.
I'm on.
I got you guys in the bubbles.
We break it.
Break it.
Yeah, break it.
I think that's strange as all, I'm pretty sure.
Don't worry.
I took him off.
I knocked him off.
He's flying his way.
Oh my god.
Wait, this is 100% loosable.
I did something crazy.
Right.
I didn't mean fall off the map.
I'm going to my wall.
I'm going to my wall here.
I'm dead.
I'm trying to not see nine.
I got him off.
I killed one.
Who fell off the map?
Craigie fell off the map.
Craigie, no strange swap.
Black is alive.
Craigie didn't want to swap for strange.
No TP.
We walked over!
Oh my god!
89.
Oh my god.
We need to be more specific when we say you do something crazy.
You fell off what happened in Swap Street.
Oh my god.
By the way, this Moon Knight skin, when you hit an E, like an onk and it hits someone, it makes this like iconic like teardrop like awesome notification.
It's sick.
that was crazy awesome all right i guess these teams are balanced bro what was i thinking highly recommend by the way yeah we just need craig to fall off the map where true what are you doing what would you say you do here we should have won i'll be i told you i do something crazy for the day i'm the wild we actually trolled wait what's next this is the next thing what are you saying that line one we serve them we serve through really hard oh we're doing all angela free flight battle yeah dude i'm in this is gonna be lit brother no one's gonna do any damage to anyone ever just gonna be trying to pull each other right you can start it whips i have to run wait can we pick maps for that well jma king in an ad that's crazy okay can we pick like a specific map where the all angela do you think you want to be today uh can we do it here can everyone go oh an ultra seal is not bad oh i was gonna say we you pick a map where it's just all like environmental kills this is gonna be lit this is
gonna be oh wait we can ban and competitive dude I want to do it so bad bro I want there's no way so there's no way so 16% is gonna win this.
Oh my gosh, okay.
They were so organized, they didn't ban anyone.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, man, wow.
I mean, the gamble is the fun of it.
That was hilarious.
60%.
Hey, give me to Vegas.
I like those odds.
Imagine if we did ban Angela.
I never get invited again.
I respect the group ban, dude.
definitely it's definitely a sign oh no no don't even too much drama what can i say bro target man so this is a new house last night competitive angela i'm in this is just a new mode right yeah where you can like no character limit kind of a thing yeah yeah
It wasn't when I banned Dr. Strange when I banned Root and then I got pulled off of the game.
Like, she's very robust.
I never learned my lesson, apparently.
I just never learned.
Wait.
Let me show you guys the flying.
Come back, come back, come back.
What happens if it's like all strange and we put 12 strange portals on the map?
All right, crack.
You want to get the alt at the same time.
I'm ready.
I'm taking them all off the map.
I'm taking them off the map.
I'm going to try with you, brother.
Yeah, we're all trying.
Are we all doing it?
We all have to take one, guys.
What if they're also...
What if they're...
What did he come up with?
I don't know how this is going to work.
Just hit shift and go.
One each.
I got two.
Oh, it is.
That didn't work.
Oh, you can bump into each other.
I got one.
I got Tsai Kudo.
Oh my god.
They're playing the spawn room.
Retrieve!
Wait, never give up.
Never give up.
Nick A30 talked about it, bro.
I'm on Moxie.
He's gotta die here.
Where is he?
Try!
I'm abandoning.
I don't know where they are.
I never played it.
I'm dead.
I can't tell where anything is.
They went back to sky.
I'm on the card.
I'm gonna go die.
Going on the card, guys.
Oh wait, Sam.
This is so hard to control.
No, you guys don't understand.
This is actually so hard to control.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, okay, I'm coming now.
They have been seen and they will not escape.
Oh hey, they're all on me right now.
I fly away.
I'm here.
Oh my god!
I knocked someone down.
They're all on me!
I'm okay.
1HB!
No, no, no, no, no!
I'm not gonna spawn!
Who, I got you!
Foxy tried to creep me out of the air, bro.
Get him!
I got you!
What?
Let's 2B1M!
No!
He came to the alleyway!
What?
What's going on?
I'm playing Mad Kid, playing Mad Kid.
Yep, you're good.
I'm swinging.
Wait, what?
I mean, it's so chaotic.
It's so hard!
Find me!
No, no, wait, wait!
I got my old!
Wait, who has all?
Who has all?
Oh!
Oh, I got no!
Wait, we should just chain her all up.
I want to just like make them come back here.
Oh my god, I'm being taken.
I'm ulting right now.
I got two.
I'm here with you.
Oh, we're, they all ulted.
This is just a chain.
This is just all the stairs.
More and more.
Oh, more and more and more.
Oh, my god.
We're losing.
I'm losing.
I threw like three.
We have like three ults now.
We threw like all.
We threw six ults actually.
Don't hit tab.
You have zero elips.
You want to know what you're doing, bro?
All right.
I am being targeted, all right?
Someone has a donut and it's not in real life.
You know what, dude?
Watch this game change at all.
Who gave us Owen?
Oh, he got it.
He got it killed.
He did it.
Look at this game changing, old.
Oh, my God.
Game changing.
You like that.
You gave him motivation.
And get your health kids.
Get your health kids.
Let's get it.
Let me get you.
You gave him motivation.
Wait a minute.
Do you guys see this glitch?
Do you see me?
Wait a minute.
What is going on here?
AJ, AJ.
What are you going to get into, bro?
Wait a minute.
We're on T-Day.
Oh.
Oh my god.
He ulted.
Yo, okay.
Worst case scenario, if they try to win this game, we just call six strangers and then support, crash the game.
Oh, that's true.
You can't go into melee.
I can't go into melee form.
You know, I tried my best.
oh yeah they hit a checkpoint now might be a good time to stop them cuckoo oh wait i hear someone i'm here tithe i'm on xx one you can stun each other that was crazy yeah if you dive after each other at the same time you stunned yeah kind of like bucky a hawk kind of a thing he's low he's low wait one point one nice Wait,
wait, their spawn is close to the, what edge?
Their spawn's close to the edge.
Oh, that's true!
Stand beside the spawn.
I hope.
Oh, my God.
I hope that I didn't get it.
I didn't hit anyone.
Yeah, I was going to say, wait, where did it go?
I got all yours.
Oh, my gosh.
Markdown!
Wait, we're getting C9.
You're on cart.
Wait, I'm still tethered across the map?
Yeah, I see it.
brother he
is not solo oh wait i just headshot him this is crazy all right i'm alting the car yeah i'm gonna hit a fatty i'm gonna hit a fatty we got this i got two i'm like that i like that that's good
oh we're starting at the cycle we can kill the old we started something yeah you can like break it Wait, who is this with me?
Just try...
But who is that?
Oh, that's super!
I got him!
Oh, thank you.
Oh, I have him.
I don't think so.
Moxie, I don't think so.
Yeah, no, Moxie tries to pull a quick one.
No, wait, what did Moxie do?
He tried to...
He tried to 1v2 being craggy with the ult.
Yeah, no, he's out of his mind.
Craggy, I really needed that.
That's him!
He stole his outfit!
Oh, shit!
There's so many else in there.
I only got one.
Bro, what's going on?
GG, no heals, bro.
GG, no heals.
GG, no heals, man.
I'm out.
I'm helping you.
Nice.
I'm shielding.
My shield's gone.
No.
I'm helping you last.
Oh, I need help here too.
Nice.
The cart's moving.
Cart's moving again.
Cart's moving.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's not ideal.
I I got a small cart !
Someone's got a small cart!
I'm in my cart!
I'm getting this one.
There we go.
There's three guys.
I gotta run, no!
Are you okay with it?
No!
Oh, he got the health fish!
Oh he sold it!
Oh, we get this, we get this.
We get this!
Oh!
I'm 413!
Oh my god!
Okay, this is my health kit.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm 40!
Alright one more minute, we could do this, we could do this.
go huge bro okay i got you i got you i stalled you guys i tethered three i tethered three far behind yeah but oh yeah you can use it as a stall by the way oh that's cool you can like force him off point you can use it on a strange when you use portaling right i think so does that stun him with portal beautiful oh nice i saw that Guys,
guys, get the health packs.
Yeah, Moxie just got the health pack.
Wait, I hear someone behind us.
Are you changing?
I like over time.
I got Moxie, Moxie, Moxie, Moxie.
I had him absolutely slaughtered, by the way, until he grabbed the med kit.
He's one shot running away.
Yeah, he's low.
He's low.
I can't fly.
He's trying to bait.
Wait, wait.
He's for sure dead here.
Guys, why is Moxie still alive?
Yeah, how is he doing this?
How is he doing this?
Yeah, I see it.
I have a lot of people tethered in here.
I think I'm dead.
I got him.
Yeah, no, I'm in here.
Wait, did we just lose him?
Wait, did we?
Yes, I got him.
I got him.
I made him waste his old.
Nice.
He threw it on the ground.
I flew in the air and even wasted it.
No.
Moxie.
You pulled his pants down.
That's a dog.
So we are the better.
Angela team.
One of the better Angelo's, yeah.
We're the real gamers.
What are you doing after this?
Now, uh, whips, now what does it say on the dock roll?
We had, I think it's like, we can pick whatever character we want.
Was it?
Oh, Vanguard both teams play as vanguards all tanks so basically we all have to do vanguards and one person has to Angela at least hmm all right who wants to be Angela it's got to be someone and who would that someone be don't know about that okay don't twist my arm guys all right
What if we go one Angela and five pennies, bro?
Oh my god, we should, yes!
We should put like, okay, we should be attack and we should be defense and just put it all on the front door.
It's a random start, so I, like, they have a certain mode, so I can't pick, like, the map or what side we're on.
Oh, I hope we get it.
I hope we get defense.
We're offense.
we're offense oh we just restart the map and be like oops sorry from what if we what if we're what if we're five the things oh it's quabrin why we're all five captain americas and just run oh my god that would be standing spider-man that would be sick wait captain america sounds like a great idea yeah it does five captain america Dude,
if we did Thor's, if we did all Thor's, we'd all have the team up.
That's true.
I'm down.
Everyone teleporting across the map.
Yeah, the Thor is technically Captain America now.
True.
True and yes.
We got to bend this guy's out.
We got to bend Super's out of Warlock just like out of respect.
Yeah, I agree.
It's got to go out.
I'm down with that.
We do a 16% Angela right here.
Jay, you can do it.
Jay, no you want.
Don't do it.
Jay, don't do it.
what why was if i banned angela yeah you heard the only 16 percent angela way to conform bro because i would have felt bad why was it if it actually win
bro tim all i can think about is that one guy on tick tock who baited us into like ravening us into his door pick just like eating right now that thor is just getting all these buffs you know what i mean bro thore mains are on top right now bro you know what's funny i i will say out of all of the tanks no joke like no one i don't really you don't like see magneto one tricks or like they usually have someone else in their bag right but thor never gets banned ever so like i really feel like for vanguard there's really only like captain america or thor one tricks maybe We're defense.
I'm going.
Wait, wait, wait.
We're defense.
Penny, penny, penny, five pennies.
It's penny time.
Wait, we gotta put like a trail of these on the case.
I have the God spot on the left.
Do all our stuff like connect?
I don't know, but this is, dude, I literally just wanted Tyler with the setup.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
I'm gonna go, I'm gonna go on the right side here.
Bang.
Just blow the choke.
Load the choke.
Yeah.
Yo.
Load it up, guys.
Load it up.
Make a giant chain, bro.
A giant chain.
We need one back here.
We need one backside of the site.
Yo, we are not losing.
There's no odds with it.
Last, last, try and pull them into our trap, bro, with the spear.
Oh, they're walking.
They're all walking, dude.
Wait, wait, we got hide.
We can't show them.
We can't show them we're five pennies.
We can't.
Why didn't you show?
Oh, dude, that was actually like a really hard gamma shield.
Dude, they're all caps in America.
They're going to walk into my mines.
Oh, yeah.
Look at this.
You see that?
They'll never know.
He's going to hit X.
Jarvis blows house up.
I got news for them, bro.
They're not getting this point.
Yeah.
No, they're not.
This is an impenetrable defense here.
Oh my God.
There is no beating this team.
Look up.
Look up real quick.
What?
Oh, Ty's got some...
Ty's got some new petty tech going on.
I got some...
I'll put some mines in the back there.
Oh, my God.
Super grab me.
You're not...
He's not...
They're not getting out into here.
Look at...
Dude, they all connect.
Look at how excuse he tried to run away.
Keep putting down mines main Get about are mines unlimited like yeah, but you got like you can have like 20.
I think you have 20 Oh, 10.
Oh, 20.
Yeah, no, you can have a lot.
Keep spamming him.
Oh, they're putting him back
Wait, don't we still oh we should have had a rocket don't we get an extra one?
No, no, yeah, but it's vanguards only Oh
Well, they'll be able to get through.
I'm going to catch another one.
But they'll be able to...
I think...
I see all...
I hope the guys are all there, right, bro.
Flanking, flanking, flanking, flanking.
Don't worry!
I'm just holding left click forever.
Oh, no.
We lost a penny.
Jay, get back to sight now!
I'm coming.
I'm coming!
I'm ulting!
I got her!
It's not about it!
Save him!
I saved you!
Wait, I'm going to connect to all this, aren't I?
Yo, this is crazy.
Thank goodness we don't have to play defense.
Yeah, they're going to portal.
They're going to portal.
Yo, you get healed on the webs, too, bro.
This is actually insane.
Didn't work out.
TP.
Cancelling, canceling, canceling, canceling.
Cancelling, canceling, who's going to cast?
Oh, none of us can make it.
Did you cancel it?
yeah that's so toxic to hex is gonna tweet keep putting mines keep putting mines cranky you kill first for the for the petty you're fighting right oh my god look at all the mines oh my god oh my god there's so much fear they try to kill the spider mines they my spider buys live oh my god this whole place is a bro and they all they all chain together so like they all help each other out it's actually insane this is gonna hurt this is a little broken thank god there's hero limits guys i'm actually trying to play this in rank uh they have six pennies what do you do oh my god i'm dead oh my god don't worry i got my desk on the left Are you losing?
Oh, oh, no.
Oh, no.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Waiting, wait.
No no, no, I'm TPing M Chad's map.
I'm TPing Moshi off the map.
Oh, you are not.
Oh, here, here.
I'll do another portal.
Oh, we're in your chair.
That chair's a cooldown.
Get back to the point.
I'm still alive.
Somehow.
Get back to the point.
Doki with an elimination and the stall of his entry.
Please.
I stalled for so long.
Oh.
Reinforce!
You guys made it.
Put on your mines.
put on your mind it's not what about i'm melting i'm melting right there's an enemy penny that's not ours that's not our penny what's doing so nice
all right put up put our minds back guys i'm setting my perimeter i'm setting my perimeter this is gonna hurt i'm my perimeter my perimeter behind there's behind so it's flying oh my god oh my god it's a strange
I just like grappled him again.
This is so troll.
Oh, my God.
Look at all the spiders.
Oh, my goodness.
Marvel, I think we should let everyone play Penny on one team.
Thoughts?
Oh, my God.
That's too funny, bro.
Oh, we should have no limit.
We should bring no limits into rank.
Was that my idea?
I think it was Tim.
idea yeah i mean dude it's a it's a golden idea and i stand by it
like how do you get past that like i don't i literally i'm not kidding i think you have to go squirrel that's the only solution i don't think any take account of that they just bank off the walls yeah uh what's oh we just go again so wait whips what's the rules on this one then we have 12 minutes
all duelists or we all supports I wouldn't mind like 12 Jeffs 12 Jeffs oh that would be so fun do you want to do 12 12 Jeffs are like 12 12 invisible women would be pretty nasty to everyone just throwing everyone just pushing and pulling everyone around 12 Iron Men would be funny too maximum it's a happy death yeah That was fun.
Ooh, 12 Black Widows would go crazy.
That was fun.
I think that was actually...
I'm glad I was not on attack.
I'm so happy because I feel like they would have done the same thing.
I feel like I'm so happy.
We did not have to play against that.
I would have been so angry.
So does Moxie and like Super live in the server or...
Looks like it.
Nine MS.
They did not have to fight.
As long as...
I had fun though guys.
I had fun.
What are the odds about?
What are the odds?
Oh, it's Central Park.
Oh, it's Central Park, my favorite.
Wait, this is...
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, it's a different map, Tyler.
No, I'm pretty sure this is the same exact one.
It is the same exact one.
Yeah, so Tyler's right.
So do I back out?
Say that one more time and I gotta unzip real quick.
All right, go.
God, wait, what?
Tyler's right.
Oh, my God.
No one ever says that.
Nope.
So do I need to be kidding.
You know what's funny?
No one's ever, I don't think anyone's ever said that to me, bro.
Like, I think you just like unlocked like some trauma.
I think you just healed some trauma.
Thank you, man.
Oh, my God.
They banned Benny.
That's fair.
That's so fair.
I'm betting I'm more lucky.
in bye bye bye bye i'm winning this i'm winning this oh you're not jane no you're not 16 does not win i definitely watch this i see it like always win if you win i'm putting a thousand dollars on smu or you can just give me the thousand oh damn i was gonna send you a thousand too jay imagine if we were all adam warlock though that born again no one would die they have infinite heels unless you like full right-click headshot wait wait would that be a endless cycle mess with them and we go six loki's and everyone has three oh my god wait yeah we'll play high and seek we'll try and find a real loki we all we none of us move yes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and you guys can't move Like you can't even see if it works.
Let's just see if it works.
Even if you're being shot, you can't move.
Okay.
You have to just, okay, dude, this is great.
Even if, even if you, you cannot move.
They'll never know.
Just put them all over the point.
Put them all over the point.
They're like, which was the real one?
Just correcting.
Yo, this is great.
It is easy.
Yeah.
Bro, this is going to be insane.
Okay, so really try hard not to move, but you can still press like left shift right get your whatchamacallit's out your lanterns out and stuff look at all that we need a few more we need a few more we're playing hide and seek i'll put one on point hang on oh my god i can't do it oh wait on jeff they think everyone should hit shift at like the same time yes yes yes call up the shift call it out okay are you guys ready oh they're not coming in here yet
Wait, they don't know which one's the real ones.
They don't, bro.
And then they take your clothes, put on new clones.
Wait, one's going strange?
They're gonna try to TP?
Wait, one's going to BP.
Well, we should have been strange, huh?
Yeah, yeah, we should have been strange, I guess.
Wait, the map's moving me!
You're trying to take me off the map.
Move up a little, move up a little.
I gotta move.
move i gotta move i'm they're like which was the real one oh no super went moon night dude we're sorry no we got this just all we have ship we just got killed one super i have to shift i have to shift i can't even see him i'm pretty sure about the yonk what have three clones up i don't i do I'm shifting I have to they have a they have a BP oh my god they're going full low-key counter I shifted as well I got you I got you no man down working it's not working they quit full counter they're not fucking around anymore they're leaving me they're leaving me I'm dad the moon night place they would hide and seek I got the TP down Yo,
I'm coming out as Spider-Man thoughts I'm gonna go black widow dude TP's still there TP's still there I'm somehow alive I'm my dad's character Oh, goodbye All right, what's right now we go back we go to Jeff Three Jeff's and Jeff's right, I'm down yeah we could go one hulk and five no more oh wait that sounds fun all right after we all guys on the left i signed him let's go no dude we're so fast now
dude wait one jumps is kind of insane
down oh no he led us into the room oh no this is bad this is bad this is bad this is real bad it's okay yummy yummy i'm back on jeff i'm back on jeff
i would say watch out bp but that's xqc on bp so
Oh my gosh.
I got you.
Oh.
You'll each other.
Yeah, yeah.
Make a line.
There's a bubble.
Oh no.
No, that was.
Oh, that killed all our gems.
What happened?
That's tragic.
Right.
They got a big fatty.
Oh no.
No, no.
Are we doing it?
Hulk no more?
No, no, no, no.
We got this.
Oh, but the edge of the map is close.
So if we get old, just take them off.
Last, this is your time to shine.
Absolutely rinsed.
Nice.
He moved down next week.
Check X out.
No!
Wait, wait.
Oh, no!
Wait, how did that not get me?
I'm trying to save whoever's in there, but I can't.
Oh, no!
He's getting coffee!
Oh, my God!
Oh, Maxi, I played me, bro!
No!
Oh!
Oh, no.
There's so many bubbles on the floor.
I'm stolen.
I need more.
He's doing it.
I'm just going in circles.
Wait, they hit the checkpoint.
What the heck?
Oh, no.
Wait.
Do you not stall when you're under?
No, no, no, no.
That'd be so toxic.
Oh, man.
Five just men.
X just peaked up and got half health instantly.
Okay.
Remember, the map.
We can take him off the map still here.
Oh, it should have been five Jeffs and one Emma.
My baby!
Moxie flanking weak?
We should push up with that.
Or Moxie's actually bad with it.
I got two flanking, two flanking, two flanking, one.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
He's what?
Oh no, he just got absolutely blasted.
Alright guys, we just gotta defend this for four minutes.
Oh, my God.
He's one.
You guys are so deep.
Okay, yeah, I got two off.
Oh, nice, Jay.
I'm never seeing you guys so deep.
You're so deep.
Thank you.
Oh.
Bye.
Whoa, that was...
He did a combo on me.
Yeah, I was like, I don't get what'd you do to him?
I got one shot.
Oh, and that's two...
Oh, it's two Black Panthers.
an iron fist.
That one.
Guys, I think they really, really want to win.
This is not fair.
They gotta go back.
Look at him just heal up when he
nice.
Missed everyone.
Timmy, come through, come through.
Hello.
I got a Jeff.
X up top X top left looking for it I'm pushing him out nice Got you last baby don't you worry.
Thank you brother.
Well, I'm just coming in only three more minutes guys Yeah, we got three more minutes.
Oh, I'm breathing on him dude.
I'm breathing on him Okay, you'll watch this actually I can't it'd be easier if they were all different characters But scooping up a Jeff is hard.
Can you scoop him up if he's underground?
No, if a Jeff old and you old I'm pretty sure you like You're running Hulk, Neymar.
Yeah, yeah.
You're running Hulk.
Hold on.
I'm going to hold away from 100 feet away.
And they're not going to hear it.
You guys ready?
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
There's a lot on the more.
No way.
You had to have heard it.
Sakuna's one.
I got my guy, man.
I'm helping you, Doki.
Oh, thank you.
I'm on Moxie.
I'm just spitting on him.
I got you.
I'm shooting the squid for you.
Why is this actually so good?
Why is this working?
Two more minutes.
We got this, we got this.
We got to win the last game.
It's all that matters.
Recency bias.
No one remember anything else.
That's so true.
No, I think they'll remember the penny game.
Oh, we'll never forget.
They'll never forget.
Oh!
Whale!
They will, but you know!
I traded with one.
I got their uh blade
I'm coming over.
Oh, that's a big one something That's a big one lasses they did the bubble Are you alive?
I'm alive.
Are you alive?
I don't know how I killed that guy.
All of us holding left click in one general direction.
They just fall over I know you a mega beam dude I was just randomly shooting my beam.
Wait, who is this?
Oh!
You're live!
You are not at that.
Oh, he's one, he's one.
He's literally one.
Yeah, I'm trying.
We're all spinning on him.
Takuno, Takuno can die.
Axe, focus Axe.
He has no ult.
We're spinning.
Got him.
He's Bruce.
There's like five beams going at him at once.
Oh, no.
This is Nerf Squirrel Girl, though.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
We just made a big challenge to us.
Everyone aim.
Aim in the tunnel.
Get out of the tunnel.
We all shoot it.
I got you guys.
Oh, that's actually so talking.
That was really good.
Nice.
Take him off.
I'm giving you bubbles.
Goodbye.
Nice.
Oh
Easy Wow, oh shit.
What a blessing.
Oh no Not those squirrel stampede Nice That was the most fun had in a long time that was a good time i like the loki's thought that that stuff was fun yeah it was like our little hide-and-seek they got confused yeah you turn the corner you see 20 loki's just no no one moving no one moving all the pennies on the first point made but the most toxic thing we've ever done yeah that was crazy bro oh my gosh my screen was messed up that whole time the fact that yeah the fact that we full held that too it's so odd well that's it right guys yeah it's been a it's been a pleasure it was a lot of fun let's yeah i'm gonna definitely just wrap up the the sponsor segment thank you guys for playing it was so much fun yeah you got it adios friends goodbye bye bye see ya all right that was so fun i had a great time yeah it was such a great team i i don't know if the other team had any fun but our team had fun my host what do you mean everyone was doing I was not the only jet player there all of us did
it that Loki shit was so yeah that was just like a little hot and serious like where's Loki where's the real Loki I had so much fun playing that it's great meaning everybody there like i said i never interacted with any of these players before um before the sponsor so i had a very fun time uh meeting them and i hope i uh i hope that they had fun too so huge shout out again to rivals for sponsoring me um i really appreciate it for those if you guys want to help out the stream and the sponsor feel free to click on the link pinned in the chat um pinned in the chat and also on the panel as well so thank you thank you rivals uh but i had a great time we Check out the early access for season four.
I believe season four comes out on...
Let me check.
Let me check when the season four comes out.
I'm not very good with dates, so I don't...
Let me check.
Do you guys know when season four comes out?
It comes out in...
Oh, wait.
It's not even in there.
September 12th.
September 12th!
Thank you, guys.
At chat.
When the season...
Yeah, next week.
Oh, my God.
It's so close.
Man, season four.
it comes out next week so i hope you guys will enjoy angela and all the new game modes and okay the the no hero limits is gonna be so chaotic for sure i i i wish one day they'll bring they'll bring it to rank for one day just to see how i would love to see them bring it to rank for one day just to see how toxic it'll get
for april fools everybody goes no hero limits for one day this i just want to know what the medic comps would be for that day but yeah thank you again i am gonna head off now um because i do have another stream layer today so i want to rest a little bit uh and i do have a convention too uh early in the morning it'll be like it starts at 3 p.m for me so i need to rest my voice because you guys can see it's a little strange from all the silk song earlier all the silk song and earlier so i'm gonna rest a little bit until our stream later i don't know if i will actually finish gears or what depends on how um my voice feels so we might just not play that long um just because i might have to rest a little bit more anyway guys as always everybody stay hydrated pause check up and move around to get that blood flow and if you stay up for me head to the bed because you deserve it for this we're new here and don't know who i am my name is dokeybird uh you usually see me stream on youtube but
today i am on twitch for the marvel rival sponsor so please Check me out on YouTube at, you can do exclamation point YouTube to check out my channel and my socials.
If you want to see me, want to know whenever I stream on Twitch, check out my Twitter at exclamation point socials.
Follow me on Twitter because I usually tweet out when I stream on Twitch.
If you want to support me via other means, I have a lot of other, I have a lot of merch going on right now.
So exclamation point collab, merch, and blade.
So there's a lot of merch that's going on right now.
So it'll be, it does support me via other memes.
And thank you all for all the bitties, the subs, and the follows.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.